well I first want to talk about your uh
especiale I mean maybe the best weekend
of my life really yeah like up there
with the wedding really yeah and I don't
even feel bad saying that all right I
don't even feel better what do you mean
up there it's like tied for first and it
might be first
thing it probably mentioned his wedding
just so he doesn't die tonight no you
will see this when you get married
that's a [__] unbelievable thing but
my wife is also here with me shared the
whole thing and she's been with me
through all the broke [__] so like I
haven't out to be like hey you you don't
mean you were at both so I can kind of
get away with it but the wedding is
amazing it's like a different level of
happiness but this was like you get this
because we're older what the one hour
comedy special has meant to us right our
whole lives yeah I remember watching
bring the pain and being like what the
[__] I remember downloading Killing Them
Softly on an album and playing on a team
you never watched a video of a wedding
and been like oh my God yeah we don't as
men you're not conditioned to dream
about so if you could if you could
relive one of them once which one okay
and with pricier what's crazier I
already lived it four times
it was the greatest and I really wanted
to say thank you first of all you showed
us we don't need the networks and I've
been thinking just kind of like
processing everything and it was no
networks I didn't even go to them I just
paid for it and the reason I was able to
pay for it is because this little pod we
started and you guys have supported us
so thank you guys yeah I was able to pay
for it it's a lot of money and it
[__] hurt to pay for but like I'm so
grateful to everybody the fans who came
out bro I didn't even know people flew
in from Seattle I mean emotional talking
about it Canada [__] Miami L.A New
York people missed the the sets we ran
in New York comedy club and they flew
down from New York we even went to The
Hamptons for it you guys went to The
Hamptons which I really appreciated I'd
have been nervous if y'all were there
I'd have been like I hate knowing a
bunch of people in the audience we got
farther so you guys did me a huge favor
going further away yeah but like yeah
people they said people were lining up
like six hours early to get front row
seats and [__] like that like it was
crazy somebody I don't know somebody
stole the stool I was sitting on people
were like trying to buy pieces of the
set we're actually trying to find a way
thank you man I didn't know how many
pictures leaked or whatever
a [__] brilliant outfit this was sick
too I'll fish out to Ross though we
mentioned them on this podcast and made
a piece to it I think you guys would
actually like
um is that the website that we went
through yeah yeah they got some fire
[__] finally bro I totally did it man
because we're going through that website
you need to update that website and just
put only that jacket up there because
the rest of the [__] carpets you had
on there were absolute dog [__] but what
is the website again
r-a-s-t-a-h.com roster
he's wearing one of the carpets right
now honestly that's a butter place this
is the first outfit that he's worn
think is like really [__] horrible
are you really good
I mean this is unbelievable behind China
your dress is like a Greek trinket story
I know how hard you've been working on
this thing and like yeah it's a lot of
pressure to hold all that together and
you [__] did it and shout out to your
boys and I'm stoked man thank you thank
you I appreciate it thank you guys again
everybody came out and I really am so
[__] proud of what so what's the plan
where do you want to where do you want
to really we're gonna I just I wanted to
just put everything I had into this
thing and I did I gave every ounce I
have and I felt like you made something
really [__] great I really do and
then after that I I'm not sure where
we're gonna go we're gonna talk some
people some networks were already kind
of talking to us yeah so we're gonna see
what what that looks like what the
YouTube route looks like we're gonna
compare and then we'll figure that out
right now just take like a week or two
kind of decompress and then get in the
edit and figure it out but like let me
just ask you one question about your
shirt yes when you put your shirts on do
you put them on feet first through the
collar why is that
I just I wore this when I like do you
open the collar and stick your feet in
and then bring a whole thing up to your
shoulders is that why because something
happens around here where I mean I can
put my whole fist into your shirt
without even really stretching the
colors I need you to explain because you
have a beautiful head your head in your
whole life has never gained weight you
could be 200 pounds and you have the
same you're not close beautiful foot
really no no beautiful [__] head so I
need to understand why the college I see
what I think it is I have a weird thing
or something sitting on my neck and I
always just suggest a collar it's just
like a weird here I'm not strong enough
but just please help me understand why
the collar is like that I think that's
why it's like that you're just pulling
it not just [__] yank at it all the
time I just don't like just anxiety
maybe it's an interesting yeah yeah it
might be okay because it's always been I
was even looking before one of the
tables she's still coming to a v before
you get dressed one day yeah I'm gonna
come to your house okay with a fresh new
shirt okay and I'm gonna watch you guys
okay because I need to get to the bottom
of this okay this to me is more
confusing than the pyramids I also like
the pyramids I understand you're putting
blocks on top of them hold them back
like just banging on his head he looks
like a bottle of acase azul
[Laughter]
you got good
oh you look like yeah
okay
okay okay go ahead
I haven't changed since the planes oh
you wore this on the plane yeah on the
flight here okay cool it's probably more
[__] up because of that yeah that I
thought about changing no that happens
to me when I get on plane sometimes I'll
turn you know it looks like you're
wearing your dad's shirt
you don't lay flat and then [__] up the
shirt bro you're doing something wrong
and we just need to acknowledge it I
could be we just need to acknowledge is
there something wrong with me that when
I sit down my pants come up to my knees
yeah do we know what it is no because
look you went back to the short joints
look have you ever seen pants as baggy
on me have you ever seen people have to
pull it out
she'll sit and watch us sit sit look
magical
that's magic yeah you and I have a thing
with clothing that cannot be explained
the bottom is my top yes it is okay yes
okay so we're gonna [__] figure this
out all right have you ever put on a
rash guard what does it look like what's
a raft guard a rash guard is like
something you would boogie board with
what about a wetsuit a turtleneck
perhaps yeah what happens with
turtlenecks
I need to know I've never wear a
turtleneck I can't have anything on my
neck oh it is a thing it's a weird thing
I have I had my whole life I can't I
hate it sexually I [__] hate it
I just anything right here I just
[__] hate it
everybody
miles do you are you he's into choking
or something he can't wear turtlenecks
they don't fit uh why yeah why
is it because it's because they'll come
up to the bottom of your nose
don't bail him out
[Laughter]
that they wear that's covered the whole
face and all the rappers
[Laughter]
okay so you felt great about the special
yeah man everything is awesome [__]
happy with it yeah okay and then you see
what happens look into some networks
maybe look into self-release there's
plenty different options are who's
talking what they're talking about and
then we'll take it okay is the shirt
stretched in the special at all probably
exactly bring it back to his shirt
can I see a picture
I don't know if we have if I have yeah
we're not being bullies I just want to
know if we can see his belly button
during the special from where his collar
we went through this one time we filmed
a Netflix thing we've been filmed the
Netflix thing with this guy and we
didn't realize it until three weeks
later that his entire bulge was in one
of the cameras you can see both of his
testicles and the penis and a small Vein
on the side he didn't realize it you
[Laughter]
so you want to take it out with the
color corrector he was trying to
increase the you know women yo what
color were the pants but they're like
what black Navy black black is slimming
okay all right and your boy was still
bulging okay so burning man we weren't
there
um shout out to everybody who went and
um we're glad you paid to the one dude
yeah what happened somebody died I feel
like that's not that bad when somebody
die every time nah not really it's
really not a lot of stuff they have a
good streak of not too many deaths there
was the one guy who ran into the fire
crazy video yeah yeah that's crazy
when they like burn either the man or
the what is it called the um Temple he
just ran straight into it [__] nuts
but who died this year in the mud there
was another Indian joke right there
about a wife running into the fire when
the husband dies I was wondering if you
would get too [__] no that was like
that's intricate that's okay yeah that
was that was really good damn it I
missed that one okay it's all good again
you could have made that one yeah you
got it I'm too tired to make the
connections I'm just hoping you would
get it okay I couldn't put the hordes
together I didn't have a big weekend you
had a big weekend tour announcements we
have added shows or more seats in the
following cities uh Niagara Falls
Ontario September 22nd winds are Ontario
September 23rd uh we added another show
in Perth Australia on November 13th uh
Melbourne we just added more seats for
the John Kane Arena on November 16th and
uh Sydney we added a second show
November 17th at the aware super theater
and uh Brisbane we just added more seeds
to the Brisbane Entertainment Center uh
guys the andrewstraws.com
for all those tickets I can't wait to
see you guys there peace also guys I do
have to mention one date coming up
September 15th and 16th Stress Factory
hurry up and buy tickets because they
will sell out they are selling quickly
also I just want to say thank you thank
you thank you to everybody who came to
my tapings at White Oak Music Hall which
is an amazing venue by the way thank you
to y'all but most importantly thank you
to the fans this was a [__] dream
come true you guys flew in from
everywhere you showed so much support I
am so grateful to you guys none of this
is possible without you and I just want
to say thank you and I know uh some
people wanted to somebody literally
stole the stool which is cool but also
some people were saying they wanted to
buy the set pieces we are trying to
figure out a way to make that happen and
if we figured it out um you can go pick
up those set pieces at White Oak Music
Hall which by the way is an amazing
venue I'm gonna tell every comedian I
know if you want to do a show in Houston
they're the best and this the whole
place is gorgeous so uh if the Link's
not here go to augustine.com but it
should be here by now thank y'all okay
so we did not uh go to your special
taping do you feel bad that we weren't
there no no I would if y'all were there
I'd have been more nervous than I
already realized you sure yeah okay son
I was so nervous after the first taping
my right forearm was like [__] it I was
like why is it so sore and I realized
it's holding the mic like this for the
full hour whatever and then the SEC
after that I was fine I felt like we had
enough with that first taping I've never
been more nervous in my life I was so
nervous and were you like thinking about
every single joke I was just saying yeah
what could go wrong what can't like you
know everything has to line up and then
yeah I was like if I hit my marks I'll
be okay yeah and then I knew I flubbed
some words but I was like with four
tapings there's this statistical
probability of me messing up these same
words three times again it's just not
gonna happen and just relax after that
you can always like go back in and
record some stuff what do you think was
your best one so after that first taping
the second taping I was like weirdly
calm and I said to Kev I was like I'm so
calm I'm not nervous I'm getting nervous
I was more nervous this past Saturday in
Poughkeepsie than I am right now and
then I got off stage and then Kev was
like that was the one and then the
cinematographer Jordan Levy was a beast
he came out and he hadn't really seen
the set that like he might have watched
it once but he gave me a huge hug and he
was like we're done we got everything we
need we have two more shows tomorrow now
we're just having fun we already have a
top tier special and then I was like oh
[__] okay that was the one I guess so
that was the taping that everybody I got
off thing and it was it was good but
everybody's like nah that was the
[__] one that's what's up we got some
moments out of there that were great you
hit everything it was unbelievable so
like they were that's when I felt bad
now that feeling was like euphoric
everybody telling me I'm done I was like
oh great we're good yeah yeah so that
was cool it was [__] it was a great
greatest weekend of my life so and now
for the hard work no I know it's yeah
that is a [__] I know I know start
organizing in your time now I know are
you off the road I'm taking six I got a
Stress Factory and then I'm taking at
least six weeks off after and then just
just organized that [__] time and
then get in there are you doing it with
Kev yeah big kev's obviously the
greatest and he's like uh this is the
part I'm excited for and I was like
you're [__] crazy yeah this is gonna
be brutal yeah it's gonna be the worst
part this is a brutal part yeah yeah the
fun is over yeah yeah yeah so it's
misery until you put it out yeah I know
and then when you're about to release it
and you're at your lowest confidence
because you've watched it so much and
you're just like wow nothing is funny
here yep in a whole hour you have to
watch it with some strangers that was a
good suggestion I think maybe you had
where it was like
let's just get 10 people in here and
just have them watch it and you'll hear
them kind of laugh at it and you'll see
how people watch the special so that we
should do yeah absolutely that you also
need like an editor you can like abuse
or like or like mock or like or ridicule
yeah take out your frustration on on the
way that their skull is shaped that's
usually people the way it works people
like that yeah Shifty really earned his
stripes that way yeah you know Shifty
didn't sleep for about three months
straight I just want to point out now
he's an autoimmune disorder
HIV dude every time we go on a plane no
this is for Real every time we go on a
plane he is unbelievably sick within six
hours of Landing unbearably sick
I've seen him not sleep for months he
didn't sleep for months when we were
doing this special the guy can't even
travel premium economy without immune
system completely failing what do you
think this is your killer yeah you broke
him yeah he didn't even do anything
the guy stopped working
he just [__] sits down
I'm trying to figure out I'm like I
might be doing I gotta make up things
for him to do
try some different subtitles or
something every week I got to make up a
new thing this kid is falling apart in
front of us right now Shifty what do you
think it is
so you can't even speak beats me dude
can't even speak dude that's it that's
all I got that's what do you want me to
say because you can't blame his employer
for ruining his [__] life he has
while he's in the room his Vlog is like
ah and that's all you got right
yeah we need Vlog energy yeah we need
Shifty Vlog energy
brother I don't need him to be happy I
need him to be healthy I'm not paying
you to be happy
I'm paying you to not [__] sneeze and
cough all over the van oh my God but he
only cares about him not getting sick
and you being productive yeah his actual
care about your health is non-existent
I've never seen something that's not
true I ask you every single day if
you're good enough to travel next week
is so angry when he found out that he
was sick it's so funny we're in the car
and then Shifty hasn't talked or sneezed
or coughed for like three weeks or three
the car gets quiet and it's just us
humming along and you're just here
[Laughter]
it was a [__] quiet place and Schultz
turns around like what the [__] was that
and literally just goes are you sick and
Shifty goes no and he says one more time
he goes are you [__] sick ship just
goes
you know it's progress it was the first
time he's believed anybody's sick yeah
I remember one time Al had like the
[__] flu
or something lazy
dying but I wasn't sick though yeah
you're not sick Bro this guy got sick
this guy put [__] hand sanitizer in
his nostrils
he Faking It
he's faking it I don't work so hard
again
he got work induced autism
I don't believe that I remember that I
was like uh what's wrong with that and
Andrew's like the flu that go really
goes that's what she says
what time again was it winter y'all all
right
there's a chance there's a chance what
do we have to do what are we doing what
are we doing it's all right who knows
dude you can't just sit there and haha
the flu is gonna stop you from sitting
there
all right
with West Village gays all day whatever
those gays all day
summer never caught the flu not one time
that's what I'm saying he's around it
he's got immersion therapy bro I'm just
saying Shifty sick non-stop I'll be
honest
I can't say what I want to say because
it could have come across as
disrespectful not funny
but it wasn't meant in any disrespect
I'm what I'm trying to say is Shifty has
a new lovely girlfriend that I think is
running him ragged oh she's sucking him
driving I didn't mean
that's crazy Mark you can't speak about
that you're saying that's what happened
I was gonna say that [__] doing
awesome adventures
if you ask me I'm just saying she might
be stopping him from getting sleep whoa
yeah his immune system is currently on
his floor and sheets
shifty is this true is there any truth
to this odds already ruined one
relationship
with Jesse one
[Laughter]
Calgary
you know when you're frolicking around
Bushwick all the goddamn time
[Laughter]
anyway oh [__] all right so what you're
going to do is is you're going to take
my picks okay or whatever picks you guys
want but my picks will probably be the
right ones uh has nothing to do with the
fact that Akash has the same picks
disregard my picks my picks are not I
would actually disregard his go with my
pictures I agree which are definitely
Dallas Cowboys Kansas City Chiefs which
I have picked because of all the
football uh I watch and uh so what I
want you to do is to go to prize
picks.com and you'll get a 100 deposit
match up to 100 with the promo code
Schultz think about that okay think
about that they're gonna match your
deposit up to a hundred dollars when you
use the promo code Schultz at prize
picks.com go get that go get that money
earn lots of it okay